for me the mentality is pretty much
everything repeating way out in front it
late for tea to bait the - yeah flee the
bodies simply the means pursue every
touch that war first wins the instinct
comes out where it's Firefly and it's
tapping into that fine
of confidence that comes with being at
the top meeting already distancing
himself from the power
tt-take see girls when I sighed breaking
World Records like wow that's gonna be
hard to break but yeah later break it
then my ass could be hard to break year
later break it and just so on and so
forth lots of five years he's not
chasing medals anymore
he totally wrecked on his mind
[Applause]
he's in a class of his own think you've
known it all you know that's when you
expose yourself to a loss and that's
what happened with me ever come off
games 82nd competing
saw that coming tt taken from the top I
hated it I hate losing deep down and no
you know a lot of people rely on me a
lot of people obviously rely on my
performance - you know they feed their
families itself so it doesn't get more
real than that
I knew I needed anger I needed to
capture that put in a bowl seal the
bottle instead of in a really slow
manner
I'm a firm believer ever since us you
know youngster that you can it get our
weed buy it stick down his path if my
body's more hammered from it and it will
adapt eventually
training is very gruesome my coach
always says you know you got to go easy
got to go easy
I always see hard work or go fasters
attack attack attack never defend
[Applause]
push your body and push your mind even
further than it should go because you
became obsessed by this one goal
becoming faster and I think I'll find
any way to win
[Music]
my star is really improved on all by
second to get to 15 meters and that's
just a 50 meter so that's 15 percent of
a race I think a finite and a 50 meters
will be fine eighty-five years
[Music]
think it'd be good for me
to leave I like to see that it's a
beatable for me I love racing the love
sports give me everything I have in this
life so every single day will never
surrender will never stop
[Music]
t7 second barrier
[Applause]